hello and welcome to word bookstores we
are so pleased she joins us tonight for
this conversation between Diana
Henriques and Joe Nocera my name is
Carrie to cusan and I am the events
coordinator and is my pleasure to
introduce our authors tonight please
bear with me through some housekeeping
word bookstores is an independent
bookstore located in Greenpoint Brooklyn
and Jersey City New Jersey we celebrated
the 10-year anniversary of our
Greenpoint location this past March and
are soon coming up on four years in our
Jersey City location tonight's event
will be taped by c-span's of PC cameras
that's why also please turn your
cellphone's off or put them on silence
after authors speak there will be a
short period of question-and-answer
followed by assigning if you haven't
purchased the book yet we have first
class catastrophe at our register our
our booksellers will help with the
signing and thanking advance for your
help tonight we are here to discuss
first class catastrophe Monday October
19th 1987 was by far the worst day in
Wall Street history the market fell
22.6% almost twice as bad as the worst
day of 1929 this incident was several
years in the making and shook the
foundations of our financial system and
yet 30 years we have not heeded the
lessons even as the same patterns were
found in 2008 s crisis tonight's author
Diana Henriques is uniquely suited to
uncovering this omission as her previous
book The Wizard of lies Bernie Madoff
and the death of trust was a New York
Times best seller and HBO film a writer
for the New York Times
since 1989 she is a George Polk award
winner and a Pulitzer Prize finalist her
work has also received Harvard's
Goldsmith Prize for Investigative
Reporting and the worth Bingham Prize
among other honors and were honored to
know she lives close by in Hoboken New
Jersey she's in conversation with
journalist Joe Nocera a columnist for
Bloomberg view whose career on business
and sports has spanned the New York
Times to fortune to NPR please join me
in welcoming Dan
Regas and joe nocera thank you very much
so it's called the first class
catastrophe and it is about a black
monday 1987 a day when the Dow Jones
Industrial Average dropped 508 points
and 22 percent more than any day in
history including during the crash of 29
1929 now as it turns out I was doing
some writing at the same time when that
crash took place and I wound up writing
a book that came out about six years
later and I realized reading Diana's
book that there were two black Mondays
there was the outsiders black Monday and
there was the insiders black Monday and
I'm just going to read you a paragraph
from something I wrote about the
outsiders black Monday and then we'll
read a little something from Diana's
insiders black Monday and we'll compare
and contrast and that will be how we
start in 1929 of course the site of
distraught investors jumping to their
deaths became one of the resident images
of that crash in 1987 there was no such
thing thank goodness
rather the images once saw that day and
in the chaotic days that follows were
pictures of people simply staring
disbelieving to jaws a gape as they
watch every tick of the Dow Jones
average in San Francisco one could walk
into the Schwab office and see dozens of
middle-class investors milling about
peering helplessly at the digital Dow as
it flashed across the large screen in
Boston on the day after the crash the
day that was a scariest Black Monday as
the Dowell worst insanely from 200
points up to one hundred and fifty
points down and then back up again
people stood outside a fidelity Center
in the financial district staring into
the storefront window where a flashy
digital sign transmitted the latest
numbers by lunchtime the crowd had grown
so large and so transfixed at the police
the company to turn off the sign so the
traffic could get through fidelity
complied no one moved
truck drivers honked their horns angrily
still no one moved they were in a market
induced trance inside late in the
afternoon one could find more than 20
people huddled in a corner around to
quote Ron machines they've been there
all day and they looked tired in days
the way people look when they're middle
of an all-night poker game when they're
sick of playing and the game seems stale
and all they want to do is quit and go
home but they couldn't go home not until
the market closed they were in too deep
thus did the middle class react to the
crash of 1987 so that's the outsiders
all they're doing is they're there just
watching the dow collapse so here's the
insiders sometime before 8:30 on Monday
and of course now I'm reading from a
first class catastrophe let's be clear
here
John Phelan who was the head of the New
York Stock Exchange asked his secretary
to track down Leo Melamed who was the
head of the Chicago Merc falen who had
cut his vacation short and flown home on
Saturday could see how the day was
shaping up and it made even the worst
fears of Friday night look optimistic
Tokyo had fallen sharply overnight as
traders reacted to Friday's epic decline
the Hong Kong Kong markets had plunged
so far and so fast that officials there
decided to close their doors completely
London was already down 10% in part
because of 90 million dollars worth of
sell orders from the trading desk at
fidelity investment in Boston fidelities
nine billion dollar Magellan fund was
the largest stock mutual fund in the
country it was chilling to think how
much of it would try to sell when the
big board open traders were predicting
the Dow could drop that morning by at
least 9% a staggering percentage figure
that was twice the record-setting 108
point loss on Friday the New York Stock
Exchange dot system was being swamped
with orders many of them from index
arbitrage errors specialists downstairs
were struggling to find a price at which
they could open trading a task that
suddenly became as difficult as dealing
with a deluge of closing bell orders
failing connected with melamed and
briefed him on the viciously lopsided
orders piling up we're seeing sell
orders like never before Phelan said
adding it looks like a very bad market
and then he said everyone loves a free
market but we need to slow volatility on
the downside if no action is taken the
industry stands to lose something at
once same event two very very different
approaches and so let me ask first Diana
what made you what drew you to the idea
that the way to tell the story of the
worst day in market history was from the
side of the regulator's decided the
people who ran the New York Stock
Exchange and so on and so forth well it
was an important point of view choice
because as I did my research Joe I
discovered that not only was Black
Monday far worse than we may remember
today it was far worse than we knew at
the time so the outsider's view of Black
Monday scary as it was was nowhere near
as horrifying as the insiders view
behind the scenes things were far more
tenuous far more dangerous there were
11th hour rescues and cliffhanger
moments and desperate chewing gum and
bailing wire improvisation to try to
hold the system together that was not
apparent to the outside world not in
1987 and certainly not in the the rosy
memories we have of the aftermath of
that crash so I wanted to be behind the
scenes because that's where you could
see how close to the precipice we really
came so let's back up a little you
actually start your book with an event
that takes place much earlier yes which
is the Hunt Brothers effort to corner
the silver market and then you take us
through a series of innovations right
that that don't really have to do with
stocks per se with individual stocks
there they're new since they're new
derivatives they're new forms of stock
and you you lead us to Black Monday
through the story of these products and
that gets us to you know thinking about
today but we'll get to that later
so tell me why you started with the
silver market and and tell me how that
leads to the creation of these
innovations and what they are and and
how it factors into the way the market
starts to change well anytime you have
to start you have to jump into a
chronology at some point you have to
make a decision about where you start
the story because you know it's all one
long continuum in history but the silver
crisis in 1980 where these two crazy
Texas oil men decide to buy all the
silver they can get their hands on was a
good starting point because it was
really the first crisis I could find in
modern market history where a crisis in
one market in this case the commodity
markets the silver market was rapidly
leaping the firewalls and spreading to
other marketplaces to the stock market
to the banking world to the Wall Street
world and the regulator's still chopped
up into their tiny little villages could
not see the whole crisis at once and as
the book opens you will see Washington
regulators desperately trying to come up
with some kind of ad hoc cooperation
that would get them through this multi
market crash when they're questioned by
congressional leaders later and asked
well you know how well did you do did
you cooperate enough they had to answer
well maybe not maybe we didn't do as
well as we should have but if this crazy
thing ever happens again of course we'll
do better and then the road from there
Joe shows you markets becoming
increasingly interconnected both by
products and by the players who are in
the markets becoming increasingly
fragile and increasingly volatile what I
was trying to achieve with that road to
Blackman
showing the forces that were gradually
changing the marketplace was to try to
counteract the mythology that black
Monday was an aberration it was a moment
of madness after which the market moved
on and everything was very much the way
it had been that was absolutely not true
there were fundamental changes in how
the market worked who the market served
what the market did and they occurred in
those seven years leading up to Black
Monday so well I'm not on that one point
that you just made about how people
thought it was an aberration they
certainly did because one of my memories
is that people who pulled out of the
market after the crash of 87 wound up
feeling foolish because two years later
and it gained everything back and then
of course it continued again and then we
had the internet bubble and so people
left it thought they had left a lot of
money on the table from the inside why
don't you want because you make such a
big deal about the various regulatory
the lack of communication amongst
regulators and even the competitiveness
among the regulator's why should you
spend a minute just to describe what
each of them were okay and what they did
sure well as the book opens we've got a
whole village of regulators there are
five major federal operations that
regulate the banking industry this is an
addition to state banking regulators in
all of the 50 states there is a entity
called the Commodity Futures Trading
Commission which regulated the old
agricultural commodity markets which had
almost overnight become hotbeds of
innovation for financial derivatives
derivatives that had never been part of
the market ecology before there was the
Securities and Exchange Commission of
course which was the bedrock of the
reforms after 1929 the SEC regulated the
options market and
Wall Street and then there were of
course the stock exchanges themselves
which had regulatory responsibilities
the Treasury Department had oversight
over the Treasury market where
government bonds traded but banks also
traded those so that was kind of an
overlapping jurisdiction it was a
fragmented balkanized regulatory system
where every it was like the blind men
and the elephant everyone could see
their piece of the market but they
couldn't see everybody else's piece of
the market there was a lot of turf
consciousness Oh unbelievable turf war
and it wasn't just among the regulators
it was among the congressmen who oversaw
the regulator's so the farm block in
Congress the the Midwestern members of
Congress who were deeply invested in the
commodities markets they looked out for
the Commodity Futures Trading Commission
uh whereas the bankers and Wall Street
they looked out for the SEC so the
politicians were playing turf wars the
regulator's were playing turf wars and
then make it even worse the legislation
was a mess the laws that created the
CFTC was one of the most elastic insane
pieces of legislation I've ever seen and
it was constantly being interpreted by
the courts in ways that through the
market regulation system upside down
by the way I propose not much Diana does
have the great fact in her book that the
only vegetable to be that you couldn't
trade on the commodities market was
onions yes and because there had been an
onion scandal there had been an onion
trading scandal in the commodities
markets and Gerald Ford who was a very
powerful member of Congress at the time
before he became President Gerald Ford
had a lot of onion growers in his in his
state and he wrote into the law that you
could have futures contracts on anything
in the world but not onions
so the second scandal that you really
talk about and I
never really thought about it in terms
of 1987 was the failure of Penn Square
Bank yeah and its effect on continental
Illinois which was a much much bigger
Bank which was buying all of Penn
squares loans and Penn Square of course
is the bank that was funding an oil
bubble right in Oklahoma in Texas so
what I'd like you to do Penn Square
eventually folded continental had all
kinds of problems but what I'd like you
to do is connect that to your larger
thesis that leads us to 87 okay well the
little oil patch Bank Penn Square had
been up streaming its loans not just to
continental Illinois but to other banks
all across the country and major banks
from New York to Seattle incurred
enormous losses as a result of one
little Bank and what that awakened
regulators to was the notion that there
were these hidden fault lines that they
couldn't see that had built up in the
system
no one knew when Penn Square down in
Oklahoma City began to shake and rattle
no one knew that it would almost bring
down continental Illinois
now continental Illinois is going to be
critical to our story because in the
days immediately after Black Monday
continental Illinois is going to make
some credit decisions that are going to
be brave and are going to help hold the
system together
so if continental Illinois had failed in
the aftermath of this oil patch Bank
Black Monday would have turned out very
very different so it was important I
thought for people to understand how the
how interconnected banks and brokerage
firms little banks and big banks
commodity markets and stock markets were
becoming by 1984 when continental
Illinois had to be rescued now you
the way you described it let me put it
this way at a certain point they begin
to invent financial derivatives as you
call them always before commodities were
traded they were there were some
physical reality to them and so for the
very first time they're basically
creating these derivatives that allow
people to bet on a basket of stocks and
it's critics would say at the time and
did say at the time you know this isn't
really stock market buying or thought
this is just this is just betting this
is just a gamble
so I guess one question I would have is
was it just a casino or did it have some
larger purpose and then secondly can you
just describe how how these vehicles
worked and then we'll get on to how they
work in connection with other things in
the market okay although I want to
underscore that you don't really need to
know how futures contracts work to
understand this story but I'm reminded
as I was writing this part of the book
about that great Disney film The
Sorcerer's Apprentice where the the
wizard you know teaches his apprentice
of a few little magic spells and then
goes off to town and the apprentice
tries his little bit of magic and it
gets out of control and he doesn't know
what to do that's where the markets were
they had a little bit of magic the
creation of these financial derivatives
initially stock index futures contracts
followed by stock index options
contracts and these were low-cost ways
to speculate on what was going to happen
in the real stock market to the real
sp500 stocks so it was a hedging tool
but also a speculative tool and yes they
did have some reason for being as larger
and larger portfolios began to grow up
pension funds in Dow
gigantic banks investing in the stock
market they needed a way to hedge those
positions and these derivatives gave
them a way to hedge and added some
liquidity to their positions but like
they tell people what hedging means well
if you've taken a stake in a in a
particular security in a particular
asset but you you're a little concerned
that maybe you're a little bit wrong or
maybe you're a little bit late or maybe
you're a little bit early you want to
take an offsetting position that will
buffer some of your losses a good
example for example let's say you own
auto dealer stocks okay you own GM and
Chrysler well what could happen that
would hurt auto sales let's see oil
prices could go up gasoline prices could
spike and that will hurt auto sales well
if you want to hedge that position what
are you going to do you're gonna buy oil
stocks because when your auto stocks go
down because oil prices have gone up oil
prices are going to go up because oil
stocks are going to go up because oil
prices have gone up so those kind of
seesaw positions where you've got a
stake in one market that will offset a
potential loss in another market is what
all this hedging was about and these
funny new toys
the futures contracts and the options
contracts were ways to allow giant
investors to do that but what they did
without anyone really reflecting on what
that meant was they tied all of these
markets together because investors using
the futures markets to hedge their stock
investments we're tying those two
markets together futures traders often
hedge their position in the options
markets
tying those two markets together
similarly some people would use options
to hedge their cash stock positions
tying those two so markets that had
previously been thought of and regulated
as separate silos
we're different things traded without
anyone realizing it had become shackled
at the ankle they they all were going to
move in lockstep one way or the other
and it was that reality that burst in on
us as 87 came and at the same time the
regulator's remained in the same
position i regulate this but not that i
regulate this exactly exactly and that
was nearly fatal I mean one example of
that was on the day after Black Monday
John Phelan the head of the New York
Stock Exchange decided to block the
computer order delivery system the
little fast-track that would carry the
orders to the floor he he decided that
if you were doing your complicated
computer-driven
investment strategies as big Wall Street
firms were you couldn't use that system
he was going to reserve that system for
the little investor to get retail orders
to the floor well when he did that he
barred from his market a group of
investors called index arbitrage errs
who were critical to maintaining balance
in the futures markets because with all
the people who wanted to sell in the
futures markets these were the guys who
were buying in the futures markets but
they were buying there only if they
could sell in New York and buy in New
York only if they could sell in Chicago
and when falen said nope you can't use
our fast track to place your orders
those investors went away and the
futures market and the stock market
spiraled away from whether one another
their prices diverged and it was nearly
fatal for both markets
now there's another invention at the
same time which got in retrospect a lot
of the blame whether correctly or
incorrectly for black mark for Black
Monday and that is portfolio insurance
right so one it be worth and I remember
certainly at the time reading article
after article about portfolio insurance
and how how could anybody have thought
this could possibly have worked and and
how portfolio insurance had actually
accelerated the problems and
now this was a this was an innovation or
a device that needed to go away I think
it actually did go away
but you in your book basically found the
people who more or less invented it yes
and who made a nice business for about
five years selling it so tell us a
little bit about what it did and how it
relates to these sizes this
interconnection that you're talking
about and then what well then from there
I think we'll just go into and what
happened at Black Monday and how all
these events each other
well portfolio insurance was basically a
hedging strategy that relied on a
computer formula to tell you how when to
sell and how much to sell in order to
reduce the risks in your portfolio and
it went viral in 1984 85 86 big pension
funds eight of them they said oh this is
great we can we can have these big
portfolios of stocks which you know are
riskier than we normally want to be but
we're hedged with this new product which
would do what which would automatically
sell yes it would automatically sell
down your stock portfolio in exactly the
right proportions now remember you've
got a portfolio that is trying to track
the S&P 500
that means you own some representative
proportion of the S&P 500 and you've got
to sell them in exactly the right
proportions to continue to track that
index these computer programs would
direct when you would be selling how
much you would sell and you would say in
advance how much of a risk you were
willing to take so if I've got a 100
million dollar portfolio and I tell you
my portfolio insurance salesman
okay I can swallow a 5 percent loss but
after that I don't want to lose any more
well they would design a computer
program that would manage the sales of
your stocks in your portfolio to an
extent that by the time the
market had fallen 5% you're all in cash
all your stocks are sold so it would
manage the sales and on the upside the
purchase of stocks for big institutions
with so that they would continue to
track the market up and down it in some
ways it was a it was a pretty simplistic
idea but the big problem with it was if
everybody tried to do it it meant that
everybody was going to be trying to sell
at the same time everyone using
portfolio insurance who is trying to
adjust to a 5% drop in the market
they're all going to be selling at the
same time to whom you would say well to
whom are you gonna sell who are the
buyers going to be and this disconnect
between the way the markets
traditionally work and the way these new
players wanted to use the market is
where we really started to get into
trouble on Black Monday alright so let's
talk about that a little bit in the
run-up to Black Monday the the market
basically peaked in August 1987 which
was a five-year bull market now again
from the outside perspective you would
say well of course we're going to have a
correction or a drop because especially
for most of 1980 1987 the market had
just gone bonkers that was up like 40 or
45 from January dawg absolutely rocket
so you would expect some kind of
correction even without computerized
trading portfolio insurance and like
that but what happened after August was
the market started to make these
gyrations that were very unusual ups and
downs hundreds of points at a time 50
points 60 points and then eventually 100
points at a time
what what was that signal signaling what
was actually happening when that when
that was going on well just to back up a
little bit on that data that was not a
new phenomenon
markets had been
Jai rating inexplicably for more than a
year almost two years there were dates
on the calendar that people would look
at and say oh my goodness this is a date
when some derivative in Chicago is
expiring and those traders are all going
to slam into the in market witching out
triple witching hour double witching
hours triple witching hours and the
stock market got used to those that had
been going on for a couple of years they
knew oh well stay on the sidelines on
this Friday of the month you know don't
get get out of the way because the big
institutions are going to be slamming
the closing bell and it's gonna drive it
up or down by massive amounts so this
weirdness had been going on for a while
but then it started to get weirder and
weirder and starting on January 23rd
which one of the craziest days in the
stock market ever for no reason at all
no news no headlines no nothing the
stock market starts out with a nice
climb pivots drops a hundred and fifteen
points pivots climb 60 points pivots
drops another 50 points all in the
course of one afternoon and the veterans
are looking at this and saying what the
heck is going on so the movements of
these giant investors using high speed
order delivery systems to exercise their
strategies in the stock market had
already started to leave their mark
now as you say Joe and you're right the
peak in August was followed by what
looked for the first month like a normal
correction you know the market drifted
down all through September you know more
down days than up days it looked like a
normal correction this is how markets go
down and then in the first week in
October it really sank in one week the
market was off six percent a substantial
amount and everybody went home at the
end of the week and said well okay we've
had the correction you know we had this
crazy bull market and now it's corrected
and now things will get back to normal
the following week
a 10% drop the worst week anybody had
ever seen and somewhere in that week Joe
the psychology of the market changed
somewhere in that week actually 30 30
years ago tonight things started to
change in how people thought about what
the market was doing I take the title of
my book from a statement that John
Phelan made to Congress early in 87 when
he predicted that all these new trading
strategies that these giant investors
were using were some day going to turn a
normal market downturn into a first
class catastrophe no but what made him
say that what made him think that
January 23rd oh because he was seeing
these crazy movements in his market wild
swings on the upside and downside you
know it a nosedive at the closing bell
things that had were not normal in his
long experience and he'd been on the
floor of the stock exchanges whole life
as a trader so he knew that the markets
machinery was working and jerking in
ways that had never done before so he
was attempting to wake up regulators and
policy makers and lawmakers to this
genuinely new thing that was that was
affecting the way his traditional market
worked um so when Black Monday took
place after this I mean I guess the real
question is do you really do we know
what actually happened or is it still
something of a mystery in terms of what
was the effect of portfolio insurance
what was the effect of these options
these new futures and these options how
much did just plain old-fashioned
selling of stock by fidelity investments
by States by everybody by Vanguard play
into it that you know how much of it was
the old world and how much it was a new
world and how much of it was the
interaction between the two we know that
a lot of it was the interaction between
the two and that was the genuinely new
thing we know that there
some old-fashioned selling fidelity
investments was one of the few mutual
fund houses that had to sell heavily on
Black Monday most mutual funds didn't
but it was one of the few that had given
investors the right to pull money out by
telephone and so because they'd made it
easy for investors to panic investors
panicked so they were an old-fashioned
seller they were selling to raise cash
to give people their money back but the
the biggest impact on the markets were
the interactions between these
sophisticated computer driven investment
strategies and the marketplace itself it
the market was simply not able to stand
the torque of this selling that it was
not built for that kind of selling
avalanche and in the post-mortems sum as
you know still disputed but I don't
think there's any dispute about the fact
that portfolio insurance was indeed a
factor in Black Monday as were several
other computer driven strategies they
had genuinely changed the way the market
worked another thing that was
significant in the post-mortems of Black
Monday is how few big traders had the
bulk of the impact on the market in one
of the post-mortems they identified 10
10 giant traders who did a substantial
percentage of the selling on Black
Monday and in the days after so one of
the things we learned after Black Monday
was the big guys are here and when they
all run over to one side of the boat at
the same time it's going to capsize and
these were genuinely new features of the
market they hadn't arisen overnight
that's why I start my story when I do
but they had fundamentally changed the
way the market machinery worked and
that's what we learned
so why didn't we wind up with a total
collapse of the market in other words
why did it recover
well that's one of the most exciting
chapters in the book Joe that's why it
was luck
improvisation personality there were
deals struck in the middle of the night
on a handshake that prevented a firm in
Chicago from defaulting there was a
banker in Chicago who defied his
Washington regulator to prop up his
options clearing firm and keep it from
breaking the options market there was a
banker in New York Joe the head of the
New York Fed who was leaning on the Bank
of England of all people to try to give
Wall Street firms a break from a very
bad deal that they'd gotten stuck with
there were last-minute cliffhangers
most people don't know although I know
you do that for more than a week after
Black Monday regulators did not know if
Charles Schwab one of the most iconic
names on Main Street at the time was
going to be able to survive this crash
it had been hit with a ruinous loss out
of its Hong Kong office it was
desperately trying to recover that money
from that crazy trader over there and if
it had not been able to it was going to
be forced to close its doors and
regulators who kept all of this quiet
kept it all behind closed doors were
terrified that if Schwab failed Main
Street America would just panic blindly
and everybody would flee the market at
the same time so there were there was a
moment on Tuesday morning in Chicago
where the Chicago Mercantile Exchange
was 500 million dollars short of the
money it had to have to open its doors
that day and if it hadn't opened its
doors the futures market would have been
in peril the same bankers at continental
Illinois over the phone with three
minutes to spare loaned them the money
so that they could open their doors so
how did we get through it personal
relationships improvisation
accidental leadership a lot of luck some
some arm-twisting and and and subterfuge
here and there it was a it was a near
run thing and you could you could never
write the rulebook for how to do it
again
it was it was just too much serendipity
you can't count on those kinds of
relationships and last-minute rescues
getting us through the next time so
speaking of the next time so let's talk
about that for a second you know we have
the same regulators we have the same
turf battles as I can tell we have
vastly more sophisticated instruments
vastly larger investors as we found yes
as we found out in in 2008 yeah so if
they were putting aside leadership
issues or if there were another event
like 1987 which seems like this
certainly could be I guess there are two
questions really one is is the market
better at dealing with the trading with
the back-and-forth with the strategy
with the interconnection of the markets
than it was thirty years ago that's one
and then second you know it's the
government better at understanding the
interconnectedness and the importance of
understanding how one market affects the
other well certainly Black Monday wasn't
totally wasted on the regulatory in Wall
Street community but one of the most
distressing things about my research was
seeing how little effect that knowledge
has had in the aftermath of Black Monday
one of the best Blue Ribbon panels
recommended that one of the premier
steps that needed to be taken to
strengthen the market was we needed a
unified regulatory system a regulator
who could have a 360 degree view of the
whole marketplace and we needed that
right away this ball can
system was dangerous and couldn't work
that was in the Brady Commission report
in 1987
fast forward to 2008 as you know in the
congressional hearings held after 2008
federal regulators Chris Cox from the
SEC former Treasury secretary John snow
testified before Congress that one of
the big problems they had in 2008 was we
had this fragmented regulatory system no
one could see a 360-degree view and that
needed to change it was dangerous and we
needed to fix it just a few weeks ago in
early October the new Treasury
Department in the Trump administration
released a report on u.s. capital
markets and right there on page 9 and 10
of the executive summary it says that
among the significant challenges facing
US capital markets today overlapping
mandates jurisdictional friction this
fragmented regulatory system that we
have so I don't know what has to happen
for us to finally wipe the board clean
and build a regulatory system for the
market we actually have it hasn't
happened yet and I hope that it doesn't
have to be worse than Black Monday for
it to happen
but we really have to recognize this as
a critical issue so it is that seeps
over into your politics question where
is the leadership in Washington that can
get this done and I wish I could be more
optimistic there just does not seem to
be the bandwidth in our political
environment right now to undertake a
stem to stern renovation of our
regulatory system however overdue it is
however desperately we needed so I'm not
optimistic that will sail into the next
financial crisis in its sturdy or ship
than we sailed through the last so we're
basically counting on the banks and the
traders to control themselves we are we
are hoping they will be good
hold on one second hold on one second
okay sure
the people that have the most capital in
that in the market do you think maybe
they have too much power in keeping it
from being regulated because it seems
that every crash that happens
someone's benefiting greatly and you
know there's incentive to not fix it
because we always seem to bounce back
and then people forget about it so I'm
wondering if there's if that's what's
going on here if it's not just turf wars
but like the turf wars or by design well
that's a very good point because
certainly Wall Street has been resistant
to regulation since the 1930s there's a
long history of that part of the reason
they are resistant I'm a little bit
sympathetic to because they feel like a
lot of these regulations are drawn up
for a world that doesn't exist and
they're right you know of all makers in
Washington are writing rules for a
market they barely understand and Wall
Street is saying you that that doesn't
fit reality okay I got that but Wall
Street's not sitting down with
Washington and trying to come up with a
regulatory system that will fit reality
and as to the the scale on the size of
the big guys it is staggering how big
the big guys today are yeah to major
money managers a firm called Blackrock
and Vanguard mutual fund house two of
them together managed ten trillion
dollars so that is that is a figure
which would have blown the circuits in
1987 and it was it's a figure that would
have been outsized and frightening in
2008 and yet we have not found a way
through regulation we have not found a
way to tamper the growth of these
behemoths who wander around in our
marketplace I tell my husband I said you
realize that individuals like us we're
just the mice on the elephant's dance
floor here I mean if the if the
elephant's start to boogie you better
just get out of the
way because these big guys are so big
that their impact on the market is
really hard to anticipate you know
though Vanguard and Blackrock that are
interesting because they're they there's
fundamentally indexing most most
everything right and that gives me no
comfort whatsoever there are which is to
say they're all trying to track specific
market indexes which means they are all
buying and holding the same stocks and
if they have to come up with cash to
give you your money back Joe they'll all
be selling they'll all be selling the
same stocks at the same time so indexing
while perhaps a low-risk strategy for
you or me for the marketplace if
everybody is indexing we're in a lot of
trouble because it means everyone's
going to be buying and selling the same
limited collection of stocks at the same
time but but that is true of everything
in the market I mean that is that is
fundamentally what happens in the market
is that same thing with portfolio
insurance same thing with using stocks
stock index futures to hedge is you get
a strategy it makes sense
everybody does then everybody starts to
do it and then it doesn't make any sense
anymore because if everybody's doing it
you know once things turn who's going to
who's going to be on the other side of
the trade and and you're absolutely
right that this euphoria that we see in
the markets time and time and time again
are is the notion that it's different
this time you know this time it's
different this time everybody can do the
same thing and it'll turn out okay
that's never going to be true one of the
guys one of the professors who invented
portfolio insurance one of the more
poignant group of people I talked with
told me that he thought very early on in
this creative process he said well how
would this turn out if everybody does it
and he said I didn't like the answer I
got but he truly didn't believe that
everybody would do it
in fact far more people
than he ever dreamed and it became far
more destabilizing well asked the same
question about index funds
what happens if everybody is an index
science
what happens if everybody is in index
related ETFs and exchange-traded funds
we get these fads in the marketplace
that where we say well if a little of
them is good more of them is better and
in fact up to a point that's true
and then after that point more of them
is just more of them and more and more
people driving to try to get through the
same doorway at the same time so we need
to be alert as individual investors to
when that's happening to win markets
have overdone a good thing too much of a
good thing is a market crisis did give
another question I have one more
question I guess this is just
speculative but you know in the 90s they
had the internet bubble and while we
were in it everybody thought that the
future is really bright and then it
crashed and we're like duh this was an
internet bubble and then the housing
bubble the same thing so I'm wondering
as someone who's done a lot of research
about this what bubble are we possibly
and now that we're not paying enough
attention to do you is there any I I'm a
little bit afraid Joe can argue with me
on this but I'm a little bit afraid
we're in an indexing bubble
I think we've we've embraced one market
strategy to the expense of a lot of
others and that that needs to be
examined and need we need to stress test
our markets for how well they're going
to handle that I'm especially concerned
about the index driven ETFs that are
becoming so popular as individual
investments so those are the two things
that worry me I know I don't disagree
with that I would also add though that
when you look at certain stocks like
Netflix Facebook Google with alphabet
that have outsized outside stock prices
I'd be nervous about those two yeah the
trees don't grow to the sky and when
you've already seen something grow that
much your so that they're the idea fads
and manias are always going to be
dangerous in the stock market if that's
all the questions I thank you guys for
coming down to word and having this very
interesting cover thanks for having us
thank you